[Music]
okay we're back here on overtime let's
get to a question for you Mario Batali
do you still hold fast to your
criticisms of the banks yes you got into
a little hot water there um Bill Maher
style Bill Maher style
I discussed at a meeting about who
should be on the cover of Time magazine
right who has changed the news the most
this year right in comparing certain
characters who have been on the cover of
the magazine over the past there was a
unfortunate miscommunication that I
thought they were like a brutal dictator
who killed thousands and millions of
people in fact I believe that bankers
have done a lot of things but I think
the fault lies just as much in the but
the government that gave them the cheque
and said it ended this you really don't
think bankers as bad as they are or
anything like Hillary's absolutely it
was I do not right okay so you know
people people look for things to get
outraged about there's lots of people in
this country who have nothing better to
do then sit there and wait to get
outraged okay glad we agree I'm glad I
could help them and we're working
through it alright for you congressman
are there any policies you'd agree to
compromise on or would give President
Obama more than you got in return we're
looking to make sure that we get through
this year over this election year
realizing that President Obama wants to
take things in one direction because he
believes that that will do best for
America and those of us the Republican
Party want to go in another direction
because we believe that's best for
America we're gonna have to get through
this year and the American people will
decide when they go to the polls what
direction they want to go right now
they've split police a direct people who
disagree but but you know I think again
it gets exaggerated how far he wants to
take it you were in Congress in the 90s
you came in an 89 Clinton came in in 93
there was a tax a small tax raise that
he put forward that not one Republican
voted for the economy turned around
turned out that that tax raise really
did a lot of good things for the economy
Obama really just wants to return to
those 90s tax rates for the riches 1% he
doesn't even ask it for everybody else
which I think it's a big mistake because
at some point everybody is
have to pay Mitt Romney we found out
made 27 million dollars yes only paid 11
percent in taxes accountant okay okay
but now in the debate on Monday night
maybe you want to get rid of all of
these limb functions for foundation the
churches all these thing that you don't
like yeah I yeah okay but that's a
complete definition let me just get to
that's why you didn't pay the higher
taxes let me just ask the question let
me just ask the grants gonna okay in the
debate Monday night MIT said to Newt
Gingrich you know what Newt you're your
tax proposal is that I would pay zero
because Newt wants nothing on capital
gains and newts answer was sure that's
what I want because you're a job creator
now since mint left Bain and has been
making this 20 something million every
year how many jobs has he created no you
just really using that money because he
has you know what autism maybe just
maybe the Mormon Church has hired some
people just maybe money that he gave the
Mormon Church go into the federal
bureaucracy no I think it's okay but he
said think and what he's doing in the
Mormon Church may well be some
philanthropic goal that both you and I
could agree well you know what they
spend it on against prop 8 making sure
that gay men couldn't get mad
that was that was prop 8 which was the
came out prop 8 no one in black
community knowledge that and and there
were there were two groups of people we
pull no punches on this show I can't
wait until I make enough money that I
have a blind trust where someone I don't
know and I never talk to and that's why
[Laughter]
you would eliminate this deduction for
people to give to foundations that are
involved with religion yeah well you
wanna Mitch write offs aren't just for
religion well the charities build giant
congressmen the other the other problem
that you're you're not really focusing
on is the fact that Mitt Romney left
Bain many many years ago but because of
the way the taxation system has been
structured there's something called
carried interest and that means as you
well know that he pays a level of
Taxation on monies that comes into him
that that's not Lupo's that's not giving
to charity that's not serving churches
that's just into his bank account
'mentally what the problem is here the
resting on a partner just one other
thing the point bill just made is an
important one about the way Mitt Romney
deployed his money
we of course have and grant everyone the
right to give to their personal faith to
their church and the law allows for that
as a charitable gift how able is it or
is it political when you're taking money
that you're gifting to that church and
using it for a political purpose
opposing prop 8 that's not charity
that's actually a political spend
[Applause]
say that there is a valid point to be
made but I'm just raising that but you
also have to acknowledge the good things
that absolutely and no one's disputing
that but the point bill was making was
this individual was enjoying charitable
status for the money that he had that
was being deployed by a church that was
using it for the purposes of political
action it wasn't feeding the poor we're
gonna have to go soon but I want it one
more question from the internet who does
Mark Foley support for the GOP
nomination I'm afraid to say I'd like to
be the Wizard of Oz I'd like Newt
Gingrich's brain he's not mentally ill
okay doctor I'm sorry
Jon Huntsman's honesty okay what I
really want is somebody that puts their
country first and when he said my
country's more important than my
politics in my party that's what I won
the president and I wish I had let me
tell you not answered who do you even do
it if I had Mitt Romney endorsed to be
honest about his voting record if he
would own up the the fact that he won in
Massachusetts as a moderate centrist I
believe he could win this country and I
believe he'd be proud of that record and
say yes I voted for gay initiatives
because I actually had gay constituents
yes I voted for things like healthcare
because healthcare is a disaster in this
country if he'd owned up to his record I
would proudly say today mitt is my guy
but when you pretend somehow you weren't
there and I didn't have anything to do
with those initiatives and I wish you'd
all forget about it so I could just get
by this primary and win the presidency
so you we're all kidding each other both
Democrats and Republicans have spent
their life trying to obfuscate their
true beliefs because they think if they
say what's on the
in their mind they won't win an election
I tell you these people are smarter than
that Americans are smarter than that
and if Mitt Romney would say I'm for gay
people because they're real Americans
I'm for a centrist government that helps
people they did that to be a centrist
but I do wish you would come out and say
let's drop the gay thing there's there's
absolutely no reason the United States
government should be in people's
bedrooms it doesn't matter what they put
in their bodies those are their choices
whether its food or food people want to
go home and have sex thank you Real Time
with Bill Maher ask bill and his guests
to have questions right after the show
at hbo.com